vedete questi titoli di giornale
insistono tutti attorno un'aria
semantica la stessa aria semantica da
cui prende il titolo questa prima
edizione del pil del pid talk di sassari
l'aria semantica dell'adattamento e
insistono su un concetto che se avete
visto un telegiornale ho letto un
quotidiano in questi anni non potete non
avere orecchiato l'idea che frenare
questa enorme minaccia che il
riscaldamento globale fare la famosa
transizione di cui si parla tanto in una
parola in uno slogan salvare il mondo
comporti tante rinunce
comporti fare sacrifici comporti perdere
libertà e benessere che adesso abbiamo
in una parola adattarsi a un mondo che
ci piace un po di meno
ecco la mia tesi l'idea di cui sono
profondamente convinto e di cui spero si
convince neanche voi alla fine di questo
spicci se sarò un po bravo e che sia
vero l'esatto opposto che fare la
transizione salvare il mondo significhi
soprattutto costruire una società più
bella più giusta più democratica in una
parola una società in cui si vive meglio
e cercherò di di mostrarvelo in un
piccolo esperimento mentale vi chiedo di
provare a seguirmi prendete la giornata
tipo
dell'italiano del sassarese medio la
vostra giornata tipo nel mondo di oggi e
provate a paragonarla con la giornata
tipo dell'italiano del sassarese invidio
nel mondo in che abbiamo fatto la famosa
transizione ecologica appunto nel mondo
in cui abbiamo salvato il mondo partiamo
dall'inizio
entrambe le giornate di ipo inizieranno
alle 7 di mattina
sarete colazione con un croissant magari
non bello come questo così belli si
trovano solo negli stock internet ma
prima ancora cos'è che facciamo tutti la
mattina apriamo la finestra e prendiamo
una bella boccata
di smog chiaramente di smog e non lo
dico io lo dicono quelle centraline di
rilevamento disseminato in tutta la
città la gran parte della popolazione
mondiale respira aria cattiva aria
inquinata e si ammala per questo e muore
per questo tanto tanto da morire di più
in italia non chissà dove nel mondo di
quanto lo si muoia di quella piccola
malattia chiamata covi di che forse
avete sentito nominare quella in questi
anni
ecco nel mondo della transizione nel
mondo in cui abbiamo salvato il mondo
questo non succede più abbiamo tolto le
auto combustione abbiamo tolto le
caldaie le industri inquinanti gli
allevamenti intensivi e la mattina
possiamo goderci la nostra proverbiale
boccata d'aria non lo dico io sono
alcuni degli obiettivi che le nazioni
unite si son date nei famosi sbg
sostegni bold eloquenti gol se volete
suonare un pochino più magic english gli
obiettivi che l'umanità si è data da qui
al 2030 fra questi c'e respirare la
pulita andiamo avanti
sono le 8 e 30 vi muovete per andare a
lavoro facciamo un breve esperimento per
alzata di mano quanti qua vanno al
lavoro in auto
siete già un bel po quante userò lauti
tutti i giorni anche se non ha lavoro
la grande maggioranza se le statistiche
non cimentano sui 100 che siete oggi 70
di voi usano l'auto tutti i giorni e
usare l'auto lo sapete meglio di me
specie se dovete usarla tutte le mattine
per andare a lavoro significa uscire di
casa cercando di non pensare a quanto
avete pagato il bollo auto uscire di
avete pagato l'ultima divisione uscire
di casa cercando di non pensare a quanto
avete pagato la benzina e al naso
l'avete pagata tanto in questo periodo
poi confermati se sbaglio e affrontare i
due grandi nemici dell'uomo moderno
il traffico e la ricerca del parcheggio
e vedo qualche faccia che sbianca
dicendo queste parole traffico ricerca
il parcheggio percorribili ecco questo
ci toglie tanto tempo oltre che tanti
soldi e non parlo solo del tempo che ci
toglie perché ci ammaliamo e moriamo
come nelle slide di prima anche ma ci
toglie proprio tempo vero tempo
consumato della nostra esistenza avete
mai provato a pensare quanto tempo della
nostra vita quanta parte della nostra
vita
passiamo in macchina
c'è chi ci ha provato le stesse aziende
automobilistiche sono messi a fare
questi calcoli a risposte qua il numero
che ci interessa il seguente
quattro anni mediamente passiamo quattro
anni della nostra vita in auto pensate a
quante cose potreste fare se
ringiovanite di quattro anni ma non
potete perché la mattina auto a non
pensare al bollo auto a litigare col
vicino per il parcheggio e così via e
così via e così via ecco nel mondo della
transizione nel mondo in cui abbiamo
salvato il mondo chiaramente questo non
avverrà e non avverrà perché la mattina
e l'auto potrete andare con un mezzo da
150mila euro o ti sta privato un autobus
per la metropolitana che saranno nel
mondo in che abbiamo salvato il mondo
così efficienti capillari ed economici
che converrà a prenderle che nemmeno
dovete guardare la tavola degli orari e
vi porteranno ovunque da dovunque in
realtà spesso nemmeno ne avrete tanto
bisogno potrete andare a piedi o in bici
perché le nostre città saranno costruite
secondo il modello della città di 15
minuti cioè l'idea che dovunque dalla
periferia di una metropoli come roma
l'ultimo paesino della sardegna tutti i
servizi essenziali
le poste gli uffici e gli ospedali le
farmacie le scuole siano accessibili in
15 minuti a piedi e non è una fantasia
da ecologisti una roba che stanno
sperimentando in alcune cittadine da
poco tipo parigi e barcellona
possiamo farlo ovunque ecco andiamo
avanti sono le nove e siete arrivati al
lavoro alcuni lavori strano diversi
altri realtà rimarranno uguali e anche
per fortuna probabilmente però cambierà
il numero di lavori e di posti di lavoro
se avete letto un giornale non negli
ultimi 3 ma negli ultimi 25 anni
sentirete parlare di quel grande mostro
chiamato disoccupazione magari qualcuno
lo prova anche sulla sua pelle ecco nel
mondo in che abbiamo salvato il mondo
potrebbe esserci molta meno e non lo
dico io lo dice lui
joseph stiglitz premio nobel per
l'economia nel 2020 in pieno lockdown ha
pubblicato lo studio con una piccola
università britannica non so se la
conoscete si chiama oxford in cui dice
questo fra le tante cose con i soldi con
cui creiamo un posto di lavoro
nell'energia fossile ne possiamo creare
tre nell'energia pulita con gli stessi
soldi un rapporto di 3 posti di lavoro
nel mondo in che abbiamo salvato il
mondo contro un posto di lavoro nel
mondo di oggi delega conviene denis che
ci guadagniamo andiamo avanti veloci che
il tempo stringe il fucile hanno sbaglio
ma giustamente sono le 13 e 30 è finita
la mattina di lavoro qua c'è una grande
biforcazione il cittadino medio
dell'uomo di oggi a quest'ora si prepara
a tornare a casa una pastasciutta al
volo e poi tendenzialmente di nuovo in
ufficio a scuola in cantiere insomma
dove lavora una giornata tipica
lavorativa delle otto ore continua nel
mondo in cui abbiamo salvato il mondo
potrebbe non essere più così tanto
necessario e quello che stanno
sperimentando ad esempio nel regno unito
ho preso un titolo di giornale ma studi
simili ci sono in islanda in belgio
ridurre la giornata lavorativa oppure
ridurre la settimana lavorativa come nel
regno unito per avere più tempo libero
certo e per risparmiare emissioni
il tutto a parità di stipendio lavori di
meno produce uguale ma è molto più tempo
lavoro guadagno lo stesso lavori di meno
perdonate il terribile lapsus ci hanno
fatto anche degli studi su questo questo
studio qua in particolare mi piace molto
dice che da long run nel lungo termine
potremmo arrivare a lavorare qualcosa
come due o tre ore al giorno tutti
quanti chiaramente si intende a parità
di stipendio
ecco flashforward veloce siamo alle 21
ora di cena qualcuno ci arrivato stanco
nel mondo di oggi perché ha finito a
lavorare da poco nel mondo del mondo e
che abbiamo salvato transizione che
abbiamo salvato il mondo invece no e ora
di mangiare equo col clou di voi
potrebbe cogliervi in fallo
qualcuno di voi potrebbe farmi notare
che ho visto facendo vedere i vantaggi
di salvare il mondo i vantaggi della
transizione i vantaggi di fermare il
riscaldamento globale ma ma sul cibo o
qualche rinuncia c'è effettivamente si
legge in giro ed è vero che per salvare
il mondo dovremo ad esempio mangiare
molta meno carne questa poi se non
rinuncia se il gusto della carne come
tanti come me piace ma vedete anche
laddove ci sono delle rinunce
i vantaggi superò di gran lunga gli
svantaggi quei vantaggi sono etici no
pensiamo alla chiusura degli allevamenti
intensivi qua i vantaggi sono sanitari
quei vantaggi riguardano anche quel
fenomeno chiamato spillover per cui
negli allevamenti intensivi i virus
mutano passano degli animali all'uomo e
questa cosa è successo un paio di anni
fa in un posto in cina che si chiama one
ecco anche qua penso che ne abbiate
sentito parlare
i vantaggi di questo mondo in cui
abbiamo salvato il mondo ma non che
oltre quelli che possono essere
racchiusi nell'arco di una giornata
partiamo da qua oggi può sul palco siamo
in gran parte maschietti è un po un
peccato sono sicuro che la prossima
edizione gli equilibri e saranno diversi
ma sono assolutamente sicuro che nel pd
hicks del 2050 la parità di genere sarà
assoluta e me lo dicono loro project
drawdown un fantastico gruppo di
scienziati che si è messo assieme a
trovare soluzioni al riscaldamento
globale e fra le loro soluzioni mettono
l'empowerment femminile e la
pianificazione familiare non sembra ma
anche questo aiuta a risparmiare
tantissima co2 aiuta a frenare il
riscaldamento globale aiuta appunto a
salvare il mondo nel frattempo a crearne
uno molto molto migliore ecco adesso
quando più avanti le smettere ora i più
attenti fra di voi e sono sicuro stati
tutti molto attenti si saranno chiedendo
tutto bello ma allora perché è
intitolato questo ted talks non serve a
salvare il mondo beh perché parlare di
salvare il mondo come ho fatto io finora
significa usare una grande metafora il
mondo inteso come palla di terra aria
gas si salva benissimo da solo continuo
a fare le sue orbite con un grado in più
e con un grado in meno con un alluvione
in più o con un alluvione meno quelli in
pericolo quelli da salvare siamo noi e
allora fatta questa premessa capite bene
come assieme i due scenari che
violentato finora ce ne sia un terzo c'è
il mondo di oggi che in un modo o
nell'altro è destinato a cambiare c'è il
mondo che vede scritto finora il mondo
in cambiamo salvato il mondo il mondo in
che abbiamo eliminato gli allevamenti
intensivi combustibili fossili industry
inquinante e fatto tutte queste cose
belle di cui sentiamo parlare tutti i
giorni ma c'è anche una terza opzione
c'è il mondo in cui questa cosa non
l'abbiamo fatto il mondo in cui le lobby
che non vogliono la transizione hanno
vinto noi abbiamo perso il mondo in che
abbiamo continuato con i combustibili
fossili gli allevamenti intensivi il
neoliberismo imperante la
globalizzazione senza freni che abbiamo
continuato con tutte queste cose e del
mondo in cui non abbiamo salvato il
mondo e di un mondo in cui succede
questo
centinaia di milioni di persone che dal
sud del pianeta scappano al nord con
tutto quello che conseguentemente
sofferenza di guerre di torture in cui
succede questo un terzo di un paese come
l'italia che rischia di desertificare si
pensa te cosa significa in termini di
insicurezza alimentare o banalmente in
termini di posti di lavoro persi un
mondo in cui succede questo incendi ogni
estate più pericolosi più dolorosi e
credo che quando in sardegna di incendi
pericolosi e dolorosi ne sappiamo qual
cosina eco badate bene questo terzo
scenario il mondo in cui non abbiamo
salvato il mondo e quello verso cui
stiamo correndo grandi passi tanto che
ne stiamo vedendo il trailer in questi
giorni con gli incendi sud italia con la
siccità il nord italia che costringe
contadini a non irrigare più e anche
alcune centrali elettriche a chiudere
perché non si riesce a raffreddarle il
mondo del ghiacciaio della marmolada no
in cui il riscaldamento globale ha fatto
crollare un pezzo il ghiacciaio
uccidendo tutti quelli che è che erano
là in mezzo ecco abbiamo questi tre
scenari uno destinato a sparire a cui
gli altri due il mondo nonché abbiamo
salvato il mondo così bello così giusto
e più democratico e l'altro in cui tutte
le strutture le ingiustizie di oggi
rimangono ma sono moltiplicate
decuplicate centuplicate da un clima
impazzito
la mia domanda è quale mondo vogliamo la
risposta è vostra non ve la chiederà
troppo facile
vi chiedo di rispondermi la prossima
volta che andrete a votare al quale
politico rompere le scatole la prossima
volta ci sarà uno sciopero globale per
il clima la prossima volta che dovrete
fare una grande scelta della vostra vita
ecco in quel momento io aspetto alla
vostra risposta e sono sicuro sarà
quella che auspico io vi ringrazio buona
crisi climatica ha tuttavia tutti
[Applauso]